I'm Anthony Mackie and I'm doing the
wired autocomplete interview okay
is Anthony Mackie ding nice I feel like
I'm a very nice person
most people say I'm an ass I can live
with that but people say you and ask
because you don't give them what they
want
I'm not gonna give you what you want you
have to earn it is Anthony Mackie vegan
no I was vegan and it was the most
depressing experience of my life you
can't live in New Orleans and be vegan
why do you not eat fish here's Anthony
Mackie in endgame yes I am in endgame it
is the end of the game at the beginning
of the legacy is Anthony Mackie related
to Will Smith no but Will Smith if you
want to lie and say I'm your cousin we
cousins tell me we could be black
cousins that mean we're not related but
we say we related so people think we are
related yeah gotta explain it to it
never mind
where is Anthony Mackie from I'm from
New Orleans Louisiana
5:04 slow your roll recognized the real
seven watt heart hair Bosco vs origen
know that I'm on that ass like a
throwback real black real fast
where did Anthony Mackie go to college I
went to the Juilliard School in New York
fun fact
Juilliard was built where West Side
Story was filmed so as soon as they
finished West our story they gutted that
whole jet sharks parking lot and built
Lincoln Center and they put Juilliard
there beat that in why are you is
Anthony Mackie in eight mile yes I was
the white guy I should have got an Oscar
nomination I had to wear prosthetics and
a lot of makeup every day but I killed
it does Anthony Mackie have siblings I
have five siblings I love my siblings a
lot my sisters have tortured and abused
me all of my life and they continue to
torture and abuse me but they also
cooked for me and take care of me and do
my laundry and like watch out for me and
they're also my brothers I is Anthony
Mackie in 2k 19 I am I think I play
myself into K 19 talking to the
basketball player dude to help him go to
the next phase of his career big things
happening King shot off antenna marquee
tool' kid 19 pick it up oh Anthony
Mackie and pop who is related no just
because we have the same last name does
not mean we're related Papoose
is his own individual and and talented
in his own right how Anthony Mackie
dancing a great dancer I'm also a very
good worker let's start there I killed
the twerk how old is Anthony Mackie I'm
40 years old I'm a grown man I've been
paying taxes for 24 years how tall is
Anthony Mackie in feet I'm one inch
shorter than six-foot figure it out
homie public school know that how did
Chris Evans and Anthony Mackie meet we
were at the Golden Globes party in like
2011 2012 and we bumped into each other
and had a very Anthony Mackie Chris
Evans moment at the bar next thing you
know we did a movie together because of
we bumped into the bar he's like you
should do this movie I was like I'm
gonna do the movie so I went to Boston I
did a movie with him and then we did
Captain America together being hey what
movie did Anthony Mackie and Chris Evans
do before Captain America they did a
movie called what's your number thanks
google
how did Anthony Mackie become famous I
did a movie called eight nine and eight
mile
the most amazing experience of any 21
year old dudes life and when the movie
came out it was so big Eminem was so
huge they took the parking lot and built
a whole thing for a two-block red carpet
and we came in and everybody was like yo
and I got Tracee Ellis Ross his phone
number she never answered how Anthony
Mackie cut the check I do it right you
pay me fool
our Anthony Mackie and Sebastian stand
friends yes we are we're actually I
would say friends you know I sleep on
his couch
he's a very nice couch very nice couch
like that couch and Restoration Hardware
you want with all the pillows that has
the deep size and a tough did leather
that's like 42 inches deep it's like a
daybed but a couch it's like a $5,000
couches it it's anime and then he has
like the the cashmere like blankets that
are too small but they're so warm you
curl up to fit under him she has those
oh it's a good couch it's a good couch
you just need bigger bloody need dude
size blankets like six by nine cuz he
has four by fives and I don't fit where
does anthony mackie live presently I
reside between Brooklyn and New Orleans
in the summer I'm in Brooklyn in the
winter I'm in New Orleans therefore I
can fish year-round
I have year-round outdoor activities
playing for myself what your number is
my favorite number is 11 because that's
one twice and I feel like I'm so dope
I'm one twice I was told that by a
friend of mine and I'd kind of stuck
with it can anthony mackie rap yes I can
actually early on in my life I was a
rapper and my rap name was the wanderer
really bad I know in my high school
years we used to throw a party
in New Orleans at the riverboat
hallelujah and I was a rapper nope nope
does anthony mackie like Tom Holland you
know what I actually do Tom Holland is
my friend that's why I make fun of him I
love the kid he's a great great kid he's
the best bite of man we've had but he's
an arrogant little
and I stress little little bite-sized
you know how you have the Snickers down
you have the fun size and you got the
one that's so small there's just one
alphabet it's dead low and he has
like a size 22 waist
Yotam worth while your pants are sure oh
I will my girlfriend's pants again you
what dog but he is the best spider-man
he's the best spider-man we've had how
do Falcon get his powers in the comic
book he was drugged into a cave and
injected with a serum and came out the
Falcon and then Black Panther gave him
wings in the movies he don't have
policies a regular do but with a suit
and metal wings from the Falcon program
in the military his Falcon and Avenger
hell yeah I'm three Avenger movies in
dog treat one to treat uno dos tres Ando
tois which is three different languages
which is three so you know I'm good did
Falcon get dusted so to me
dusted is like you're covered with dust
like ashy Larry that's the Chappelle
reference cop that best show ever
I'm not a she I wear lotion all day
homey my elbows right now just
glistening like knees like butter I mean
I can literally slide across this floor
I'm so boylee right now good Falcons
wings work they do work if you watch the
movie I fly I fly quite gracefully and
proud to say I have the best costume in
the MCU hands now look at it is
my wings are delicious nobody can
with that I remember
rody I'm the fly in Avenger envision no
he's purple
he wears a cape there's no capes in the
MCU except for him and dr. strange but
we don't count dr. strange because he
likes to Thor has a cape I forgot about
dawn man I'm gonna get kicked out of
this universe Wendy Falcon become
Captain America that's a very funny
question because Falcon is not Captain
America
[Music]
today I tried jumping sprinting and
juggling all to find out why 110 mile
per hour basketball nope skipping a
stone 89 times in cycling 60 kilometers
in an hour is almost impossible